steht die supersymmetrie vor dem aus die
idee dass es zu jedem teilchen einen
zwilling gibt das standardmodell ist
lückenhaft wenn wir ehrlich zu uns sind
erklärt es gerade einmal fünf prozent
unseres universums die lösung für dieses
problem die supersymmetrie doch bisher
sind alle versuche gescheitert die
potenziellen teilchen der supersymmetrie
zu finden
müssen wir also diese schöne erweiterung
des standardmodells endgültig aufgeben
klicks um suns in future mit einer
aktuellen diskussion die momentan die
physik forschen beschäftigt hier bei
pixum gibt es dreimal pro woche solch
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktivierte glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
wie haben sich nach dem urknall alle
vier grundkräfte aus nur einer uhr kraft
entwickelt wie genau können wir uns die
gravitation vorstellen gibt es hierfür
etwa träger teilchen und wie können wir
uns die dunklen komponenten unseres
universums vorstellen die dunkle energie
und die dunkle materie
diese machen wir gemeinsam etwa 95
prozent unseres kosmos aus und dennoch
das standardmodell der physik hat für
all diese super spannenden und
elementaren fragen keinerlei antworten
wir hatten öfter schon hierbei klicks
umsatz im future darüber berichtet
fachleute weltweit gehen deswegen davon
aus das ist eine art zweite physik geben
muss jenseits des standardmodells für
die teilchen nur um das an dieser stelle
noch einmal zu betonen
das alles soll das standardmodell nicht
infrage stellen denn fest steht auch es
hat bislang allen experimentellen
überprüfung standgehalten
doch offensichtlich ist es eben nicht in
der lage das was in unserem universum
existiert und vor sich geht in gänze
darzustellen doch in der theorie gibt es
einen ausweg aus der misere
die sogenannte supersymmetrie es handelt
sich um eine art ergänzung des
standardmodells der physik die beiden
physiker julius west und bono zu - haben
diese theorie
bereits vor knapp 50 jahren ins leben
gerufen ganz grob zusammengefasst
bekommt demnach jedes teilchen einen
neuen partner
so gibt es für jedes uns bekannte
teilchen einen schweren gegenpart dessen
spin um ein halb abweicht oder anders
formuliert jedes kraft teilchen mit
seinem ganz normalen ganz
bekommt zu einem gegenpart mit einem
halbseitigen spin des bin ist quasi im
übertragenen sinne ein drehimpuls des
teilchens ein bisschen kann man das mit
dem prinzip zwischen antimaterie und
materie vergleichen doch bei der
supersymmetrie unterscheiden sich die
teilchen nicht durch ihre elektrische
ladung sondern durch
quanteneigenschaften eben den spin
doch nach der supersymmetrie müsste es
im universum noch zahlreiche teilchen
geben die sich bislang vor uns versteckt
halt möglicherweise sind wir einfach
nicht in der lage sie mit unseren
bisherigen technischen mitteln
aufzuspüren fakt ist die theorie der
supersymmetrie ist für physikerinnen und
physiker weltweit eine schöne
angelegenheit stichwort schönheit und
symmetrie beide merkmale sind für
fachleute seit jeher starke indizien
dafür dass eine theorie stimmen könnte
denn je einfacher und natürlich eine
gleichung ist desto wahrscheinlicher ist
es demnach dass sie tatsächlich auch
zutrifft seit vielen jahren dient die
supersymmetrie also mittlerweile als die
theorie wenn es darum geht die physik
abseits des standardmodells zu erklären
und tatsächlich ist sie auch in der lage
verschiedene lücken zu schließen
beispielsweise das rätsel um die
mysteriöse dunkle materie
forschungsteams weltweit suchen nach
möglichen teilchen für diese
geheimnisvolle substanz laut der theorie
der supersymmetrie könnte es sich um ein
sehr leichtes teilchen handeln die
sogenannte neutrinos da dieses
hypothetische teilchen sehr stabil sein
könnte zerfallen sie nicht weiter zudem
sollten sie nach meinung der fachleute
nicht elektrisch geladen sein sodass sie
kaum mit normaler materie interagieren
das alles und weitere mögliche merkmale
machen es zu einem fast perfekten
kandidaten für die dunkle materie so man
es zumindest einige wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler
sie gehen davon aus dass das leichteste
dieser neutralen es möglicherweise den
sogenannten weekly interacting massive
particles entsprechenden wilms und diese
gelten als die favorisierten teilchen
der dunklen materie doch diese lücke ist
nicht die einzige die mit hilfe der
theorie der supersymmetrie geschlossen
werden könnte ein weiteres beispiel
dafür ist achtung die vereinheitlichung
der vier grundkräfte die ich habe
bereits anfang des videos angesprochen
hatte also von grafite
schon elektromagnetismus sowie der
starken und schwachen kernkraft nur kurz
angerissen
die supersymmetrie sorgt für die paarung
von bosonen und fermionen verschiedenen
klassen von teilchen und somit werden
die drei grundkräfte des standardmodells
bei hohen energien gleichstark der
zustand also wie man ihn sich auch nach
dem urknall vorstellt die vierte kraft
ist die gravitation und die fällt bisher
beim standardmodell raus doch nach den
annahmen der supersymmetrie ließe sich
diese vierte grundkraft dann mit dem
rest vereinen nämlich dann wenn man die
supersymmetrie mit der sogenannten
string theorie zusammenbringt die
sogenannten strings kann man sich
vorstellen wie gitarrensaiten die in
einem mehrdimensionalen raum schwingen
wenn man dann die supersymmetrie paarung
der teilchen mit diesen annahmen der
stringtheorie zusammenbringen lässt sich
tatsächlich auch die gravitation in
einklang mit den anderen grund kräften
bringen aber kann eine theorie wirklich
stimmen nur weil sie so schön und
symmetrisch ist mittlerweile werden die
zweifel immer größer denn alle versuche
die bislang unentdeckten teilchen
aufzuspüren sind bisher erfolglos doch
fakt ist laut der theorie der
supersymmetrie muss es noch ein paar
dutzend teilchen geben und wenn wir
ehrlich sind hätten diese super
symmetrischen teilchen schon längst
entdeckt werden müssen beispielsweise
mit dem teilchenbeschleuniger large
hadron collider in genf keine frage hier
wurden bereits einige wirklich wichtige
entdeckung gemacht vor allem beim
sogenannten atlas experiment geht es um
die suche nach erweiterungen des
standardmodells das hypothetische neutra
lino hätten die forschenden hier
eigentlich schon in der ersten laufzeit
entdecken müssen denn hier kollidierten
ab dem jahr 2010 bereits protonen mit
einer energie von sieben tera
elektronenvolt das gesuchte teilchen
sollte also schon längst auf dem bad
werden spätestens dann in der zweiten
laufzeit des riesigen
teilchenbeschleuniger gas ab dem jahr
2015 tatsächlich waren forschungsteams
weltweit mehr als zuversichtlich hierbei
fündig zu werden und protonen
kollisionen sogar hierbei 14 tera
elektronenvolt stattfinden doch auch
hier wurden die forschenden nicht fündig
eine derbe enttäuschung für alle die so
gehofft hatten
die supersymmetrie also steckt in einer
tiefen krise und immer mehr fachleute
beginnen zu zweifeln so auch der
physiker michael schiffmann
der selbst lange in diesem
forschungsgebiet tätig war wir müssen
aufhören blind links den parameter raum
abzusuchen anfangen neu zu denken und
neue ideen zu entwickeln
doch welche anderen optionen gibt es das
standardmodell zu ergänzen und die
ganzen lücken vor denen wir stehen zu
schließen auf diese frage gibt es nur
eine antwort keine anderen ansätze oder
ideenreichen an das heran was die
supersymmetrie zumindest in der theorie
schafft braucht es also möglicherweise
einfach nur bessere technische
möglichkeiten um der supersymmetrie auf
die schliche zu kommen das ist die
meinung einiger anderer
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sie vermuten dass die hypothetische
teilchen der supersymmetrie doch
schwerer sind als die modelle ist
bislang voraussagen dass dies
tatsächlich der fall ist dann wäre
selbst der large hadron collider nicht
in der lage die teilchen zu offenbaren
eine möglichkeit die derzeit jedenfalls
nicht auszuschließen ist dennoch gibt es
hier einen haken und falls die
supersymmetrie teilchen doch schwerer
sind als erwartet bedeutet das im
umkehrschluss dass diese erweiterung des
standardmodells deutlich weniger schön
ist durch dieses modell nämlich cam
merkmale und wechselwirkungen hinzu die
die supersymmetrie weitaus weniger
natürliche und elegant erscheinen ließen
eine weitere erklärung dafür dass wir
die supersymmetrie bis sagen nicht
aufspüren konnten hat mit der stabilität
der hypothetischen teilchen zu tun wenn
diese nämlich deutlich stabiler wären
als bislang angenommen würden sie eben
nicht in den nachweisbaren
zerfallsprodukte übergehen nach denen
wir suchen stattdessen würden diese vor
ihrem zerfall sehr weit über den
koalitions punkt hinaus geschleudert
werden
sie würden sich also unserer suche
entziehen nicht einmal gigantischen
teilchenbeschleuniger der lhc der large
hadron collider werden unter diesen
umständen der lage sie aufzuspüren eine
versteckte supersymmetrie also doch auch
hier ein aber denn in den koalitions
produkten müsste sich dann als fehlende
energie bemerkbar machen aber auch das
konnten fachleute bislang trotz
intensiver suche nicht in ihren
experimenten bestätigen und damit zur
dritten erklärungs möglichkeit warum wir
der supersymmetrie bislang nicht auf die
schliche kommen kommt demnach könnten
die teilchen zerfallen aber eben ihnen
andere sekundär produkte als erwartet
möglicherweise sogar in andere teilchen
des bekannten standardmodells und das
wäre bei den experimenten kaum
herauszufinden schließlich gibt es eine
riesige menge an normalen konditionen
produkten von denen sich diese
supersymmetrie teilchen nach dieser
version dann nicht mehr unterscheiden
ließen
us forscher sind der versteckten
supersymmetrie bereits auf der spur
wenn es hilft alles nichts nur durch die
weitere suche haben wir eine weitere
chance eine antwort zu finden
auch der adac wird bald in seine dritte
laufzeit übergehen und auch davon
versprechen sich viele forschende
vielversprechende erkenntnisse zur super
die symmetrie und es gibt auch immer
wieder indizien für die supersymmetrie
geheimnisvolles teilchen entdeckt
mysteriöse vorgänge in der antarktis
hinweis auf supersymmetrie anklicken
anschauen und diesen kanal abonnieren
ganz einfach mit einem klick auf den abo
button hier unter dem video ist
kostenlos und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran